chappie is directed by Neill Blomkamp
and stars Dev Patel Hugh Jackman
Sigourney Weaver as well as shel toko
plea as chappie and Deon furred the band
as themselves sort of this movies about
the very first ever sentient artificial
intelligence created by Dev Patel he's
been working for quite some time on this
and he finally creates chappie
chappie is the very first ever robot
that can learn for himself that can
decide what he thinks about a piece of
art now Hugh Jackman's character is
working on a giant robot that is piloted
by humans that he thinks should replace
all of the new police robotic guards
that are so popular in this futuristic
world so from the trailers and the plot
synopsis that I just gave you you're
probably thinking the Hugh Jackman's
character and Dev Patel are going to be
blooding heads throughout the film it's
going to be about human controlled
robots versus a human robot the ideology
of that all the issues of that situation
and the big questions that that would
ask but that's not what this movie is
about it's actually about the two band
members of Dion furred stealing chappy
from Dev Patel and then forcing him to
be an asshole and chappy becomes a giant
dick for like 75 minutes of this movie
yeah he helps them steal cars he's
planning heist he's throwing Chinese
stars at police officers he's doing
everything that this robot shouldn't do
and the movies trying to make you feel
sympathy for chappie during this moment
and then eventually the movie even tries
to make you feel sympathy for these two
gangsters and you just don't
I wanted the movie to be about Hugh
Jackman's character and Dev Patel and
their scientific advances and how they
are trying to both do two different
things because that was by far the most
riveting storyline in this movie but the
movie keeps reverting back to these two
gangster characters who are honestly two
of the most annoying characters I've
seen in a movie in quite some time as
well as terrible actors district 9 is
kind of a contemporary sci-fi classic I
even for the most part enjoyed Elysium a
lot of people didn't like Elysium that
much even Neill Blomkamp recently said
in an interview that he was disappointed
with Hawaii Elysium turned out I'm
curious if two years from now he's going
to say the same thing about chappie
because this is by far his worst movie
there are certain things about this
movie that
very derivative there's a lot of stuff
about chappie that really copies off of
very good entertainment that's already
in existence and Blomkamp is even said
in the interviews that he was inspired
by certain things that I'm about to
mention however there's a big difference
between being inspired by something and
then tributing it and just copying off
of it for one chappie pretty much looks
exactly like the cyborg from Appleseed a
very good manga and anime from Masamune
Shiro the creator of ghost in the shell
and Blum campus recently said in
interviews that he was very inspired by
that cyborg character that's great I'm
glad but why not make an apple seed
movie with that character in it instead
of just taking that character and
essentially putting his look in your
movie short circuit a movie about a guy
who creates a sentient robot last year's
big hero six a movie about a guy
desperately trying to create a
scientific robot character even sitting
down and recording himself as he does it
just like in chappie with Dev Patel and
the robot that Hugh Jackman is creating
looks literally exactly like the ed-209
from Robocop it's actually kind of
blatant so some of the character designs
as well as the overall story just feels
like something we've seen before except
this movie focuses on the wrong
characters Dion heard the band okay so
if you like their music that's cool but
playing themselves with their exact same
names but they're not playing themselves
because they're not in a band they're
actually just gangsters what the hell is
up with that idea I don't really get it
and it keeps going back to them rather
than the riveting storyline of Jackman
versus Patel and Sigourney Weaver is
barely in this movie I think the largest
problem with chappie is character
motivations the choice of which
characters to stay with and the fact
that eventually they try to make you
care about some of these characters and
you don't I was actually rooting for
Jackman the whole time who's kind of the
main villain of the movie that's not
good now one point there's this montage
in which you think the film is going in
a certain way chappie is learning about
art he even watches a bit of the he-man
cartoon this is not the older he-man
this is the newer he-man I don't have
the older one yet but I do like he-man
and when I saw him watching he-man and
then mimicking Hemans actions I was like
oh my gosh this is going to be really
cool he's going to learn from cartoons
he's going to learn about art but he
really just learns how to steal cars
would you do that again I'm going back
to the characters none of the characters
in this movie feel like people they all
just feel like devices to make certain
plot points happen I suppose the most
entertaining thing about this movie is
Sholto copeley as chappie he has great
mannerisms the things they did were
astounding to look at there are some
semi well-done action sequences in this
movie but the problem is you just don't
care about anyone that's involved with
it even in Elysium okay Elysium had some
piss-poor characters Jodie Foster's
villain was awful but I did care about
Matt Damon I did care about his plight
and he brought some humanity to that
role so I cared about the action scenes
you don't care about anyone in chappie
because almost every character is
annoying as hell and you're kind of just
waiting for the movie to end which is
very disappointing from such a promising
filmmaker guys I gotta give chappie a
d-plus it's very disappointing for me to
say but by far the best part of the
entire night was the fact that I
actually had some fans come and meet me
at chappie as I posted about it on my
Facebook and my Twitter these guys were
so much fun to meet it was so great
meeting you guys one of them even drove
90 minutes with his dad to come meet me
and I talked with him about college and
his ideas about film and that was truly
truly humbling I'm telling you I was
humbled meeting you guys that was so
awesome I'm looking forward to doing
more stuff like that in the future guys
if you did see chappie let me know what
you thought of it below and as always
thank you so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes